london
greatest city in the world
well used to be
now it's alright mess
government's [ __ ] off extremists are
grabbing power
organized crimes slicing up the boroughs
the war dogs are out
and freedom's a bloody joke
but this ain't there london this is our
london
and there's a new power growing
it's all of us together
we're building a resistance one recruit
at a time
what's my favorite operative up to this
evening and no i never say that to the
others scouting talent badly so gob shut
eyes peeled yeah
i have no eyes and if i did i wouldn't
peel them
bloody drones are everywhere kicking our
[ __ ] teeth in lately
then i recommend you recruit someone who
can deal with drones brilliant never
would have thought of that
you're clear shot off
right easy i'm complying
impressive skill set sure but we need a
drone expert raj not a [ __ ] kicker file
that one away for later
are you concerned about the increased
albion presence in london
it's a total disgrace mercenaries
patrolling the streets
i ain't done nothing come on you shifted
frick hurry up well now
jimmy shaw no formal engineering
training but he has several mischief
charges for hijacking albion drones
hold still [ __ ] you man you've got no
right
[ __ ] you now we find that drone expert
and he's about to get himself nicked
a headset get
oh just ignore me
[Music]
not today
[Music]
what are you planning to tell me about
the bloody checkpoint oh there's a
checkpoint
oh
[Applause]
[Music]
[ __ ] we lost ian he's gone
lovely evening isn't it ah i used to
feed the birds here
now they're all bloody machines
get used to it in the long march of
progress everything dies eventually
eventually even you bagley i'm sure now
there's my helen speaking of death
you'll never guess what just happened to
ian oh for god's sake badly a little
respect then let's finish what he
started he was working on a new recruit
a drone expert that's promising what do
we know about him albion scanned jimmy
just before ian was killed i should be
able to predict his next move from that
data unfortunately his records are
locked up tighter than your compression
stockings
the files you stole indicate that
jimmy's gone to camden market let's get
someone over there badly chop
chop ready for some action naomi always
for this recruit better be worth all the
trouble
according to the scotland yard records
jimmy's sister was killed by clan kelly
we believe he's seeking his revenge
inside camden market camden black market
you mean
yes the kelly's a rumor to run all sorts
of illicit goods out of the old stables
some with fingers and toes
if he's gone in there alone he's in big
trouble
kelly's have this place on full lockdown
hmm
i have an idea
today everything's all fine and then
again
[Music]
now naomi we've already lost one
operative so try not to get killed or
we'll be in the red for the day
i'll be that
[Music]
what the hell
is this a meme
[Music]
ah cannabis and fentanyl together at
last through the miracle of genetics
the kellys are moving loads of weapons
out here
i'm not your typical back alley shanks
stables it's human trafficking
[Music]
found jimmy
cheeky [ __ ]
and here we thought he might be in some
sort of trouble
so um how are you gonna get him out
there
lots of hugs and kisses
well wait a minute are you dead sick i
hope you're sharper than you look
jesus christ don't let me beat these
dead priests
[Music]
does the rolling help
[Music]
[Music]
well we showed those [ __ ] didn't we
we almost died out there tonight look
thanks for helping me but i can handle
myself right
you think you're better off alone you
think everyone else has given up and
there's no one to trust
that's what they want you to think and
that's how they'll take us one at a time
it doesn't have to be that way
together
we can change things
wait
what happened to that bloke who helped
me
he didn't make it
[ __ ] it
to dead sec james
yeah
okay so
where do i go to meet the rest of the
crew you don't need to go anywhere look
around you everyone has a reason to
fight and dedsec is open to anyone
anyone
welcome
to the resistance
[Music]
so
watchdogs legion available march 6 2020
check out the watchdogs legion 101
trailer
you